here with maxime you had a solid draw
against nepo did you feel that you
missed something or did you feel it was
more or less according to plan probably
i didn't miss much uh it's just that
when i looked at this endgame a little
bit i thought i had some chances so
you know
i felt like it's the best i could obtain
but
i don't know i think it shouldn't have
been that comfortable for you and so
probably i had some
better option i just didn't see it yeah
jan also came here and showed us that
the fortress was just very difficult to
penetrate even with a best play so i'll
ask you at us we do have this result
we're expecting wesley so i did draw
against levon i adonia and i'm sure
we'll have them soon
we gotta ask you about the drama we know
that you made a comment online yesterday
on one of the twitch streams at least i
saw it on reddit was that was that you
or was that fake news
uh did i actually make a comment i mean
i made a comment on some french yes
channel yeah but this was this morning
sorry yeah
um so anyway yeah there's like a few
things i think
i mean as always with this um
uh with this dramas
it's very difficult to handle well but i
think this has been handled very poorly
because it's become basically a witch
hunt and like
the effect it can have on ants
is actually quite devastating so yeah
this felt uh bad
then
uh to whether or not he has cheated
honestly i don't know i don't have
you know
for now i don't have enough information
like if it were up to the information i
have
until now i would say not cheating
but then of course like magnus is also
not
known for going on with chance and stuff
like that so you know maybe as uh solid
arguments but
like i would like to
to see them
and um yeah if i have to end on a more
positive note i think you know these
things have been ramping
in the chess world for for the past few
years um as you well know and like it
was all handled behind the scenes in
general
but uh you know like it's and it's hard
to avoid suspicion on one player or the
other and um
if it can you know if this going
straight out
in the open uh
can help figuring out
you know ways to
like make cheating much more
uncomfortable like for instance i assume
that dealing in the broadcast
will be
commonplace
stuff like that i mean it can and for
the best
um but for now yeah like again i really
don't like how things
happen yesterday like i saw after i came
back for my game and i saw basically
everyone
going straight after her hands and like
again like i
don't have enough information maybe
cheated of course if that's the case it
should basically be done but
uh almost like for life but
you know like i would like first to to
see some uh proof or at least some
circumstantial evidence
that you know exist in some way but is
definitely not enough to
to convert to
to a certain like or even like um
a probable cheating like for now it
doesn't look probable
considering the amount of information i
have you've played hans plenty on casual
blitz i saw you play in dubai i see that
you've played him in here and there does
it surprise you at all that he has this
strength yeah exactly um yeah i didn't
come to this but yeah i played him in a
casual match in paris and like okay if
he cheated there like that you
know uh i did win the match actually but
uh it was playing very well like
definitely over 2700 of course blades
and classical is not the same and of
course is that this tremendous progress
but he's also been working on just
nonstop for
for two years so like um
you cannot like
ban a player for for improving i i feel
like otherwise you know we have to ban
every young player who has been
improving like alive
[Music]
fergananda
every casey like his list never ends and
you know i've been
at this place of course when i was
younger so of course computers were not
yet
you know part of
the issue
so
of course but i can imagine and back in
the days if we had computers and you
know magnus would have been cheating
everybody would have been cheating so
again like for now i don't have uh
enough information to
to say like
but i would say
still the fact that magnus
seems convinced is a bit worrying
but
you know without
more information i
i won't go on the witch and base based
on that
well maxine thank you for your candid
thoughts on this we wish you the best
for the rest of the tournament thank you
indeed thank you very much
maxine candid thoughts
and
i must say i agree with them
show me some evidence